und bonn begrüße ich den energie und
sicherheitsexperten dr frank umbach
selensky hat sich in davos hat sich
davos für sein appell ausgesucht wie
erfolgreich ist in seine strategie der
welt täglich ins gewissen zu reden
also in bleibt ja letztendlich gar
nichts anderes übrig inzwischen gehen ja
alle kriegsparteien
aber natürlich auch die nato davon aus
dass dieser konflikt ja wesentlich
länger dauert als ursprung nicht
vielleicht angenommen nämlich nur paar
tage oder ein paar wochen das heißt wir
müssen natürlich mit blick auf die
unterstützung der ukraine uns einerseits
nach wie vor gedanken machen wie können
wir sie militärisch kurzfristig
unterstützen aber langfristig und das
hat sie lenski ja auch deutlich gemacht
ein wirtschaftliches
wiederaufbauprogramm
müssen wir schon jetzt
andenken zu mindestens einplanen et
cetera und dahinter steht noch das
größere problem glaube ich das natürlich
sie nennt ski auch die innerrussischen
diskussion verfolgt und die gehen
inzwischen eben nicht nur von einem
längeren konflikt heraus sondern dort
wird explizit angenommen dass russland
in einem solchen längeren konflikt die
oberhand behält gerade weil die
westlichen demokratien und der rest der
welt einen solch längeren oder die
unterstützung in einem solch längeren
konflikt nicht länger durchhält und das
ist natürlich seine ganz große sorge
dass diese unterstützung entsprechend
nachlässt und tatsächlich wenn sich die
diskussionen in italien anschauen dann
wissen sie dass diese
diskussion natürlich
oder diese unterstützung teilweise
innenpolitisch in einigen ländern
sprechen möchte nur meine haken die
entscheider die interviews dazu hören
die könnten die öl und gas szene zu
drehen warum tun sie es nicht
nun wir haben ja die letzten wochen ganz
deutlich gesehen wie schwierig das ist
wir haben objektiv natürlich probleme
innerhalb kürzester zeit ein gas embargo
gegen ostern zu verengen weil es unsere
eigenen wirtschaft natürlich natürlich
auch mal steve schade zumindest kurz und
mittelfristig bei einem ölembargo kommt
ja dann noch hinzu dass russland diese
dinge auch teilweise jedenfalls umgehen
kann das wäre beim gas embargo nicht
möglich dh nehmen wir mal die
innenpolitischen diskussionen aus
deutschland oder europa weg dann wird
ein gas im parco russland am meisten
schwächen wir haben seit anfang des
jahres weitaus mehr für gas als für öl
inzwischen bezahlt auch weil die
ölimporte aus russland teilweise ja
stärker zurückgegangen sind bei dem
staatshaushalt sieht das anders aus aber
gerade diese diskussion um das gas
embargo zeigen hier auch die
zerrissenheit auf unserer seite
einerseits dieses ein solches embargo
möglichst schnell zu erheben auf der
anderen seite wissen wir welche
wirtschaftlichen verwerfungen die es
möglicherweise für uns bedeutet wenn sie
mal eine zwischenbilanz ziehen mit blick
auf die bisherige sanktions spirale was
hat die gebracht schwächt sie russland
wirklich
also das problem war ja von anfang an
und ich glaube die meisten experten auch
ich hatten ja davor gewarnt zu erwarten
dass die die sanktionen auch wenn sie
historisch präsident los international
sind so schnell wirkung haben dass dies
auf die entscheidung ein krieg schnell
zu beenden
bei guten entsprechend durch wird
sondern wir gingen ja eigentlich auch
davon aus dass diese sanktionen wirklich
über eine längere phase erst wirken
müssen und bei den ölen barcoo
beispielsweise um zwei zahlen einfach
mal zu nehmen auch russische experten
gehen davon aus dass bis ende des jahres
die eigene ölproduktion
natürlich dann auch die importe um 20
bis 25 prozent abnehmen das was dann in
folge dieses embargo umgeleitet werden
kann wird mit einem preisabschlag von 35
bis 40 markt auf den weltmarkt gebracht
dazu kommen wir viel höheren schiffs
versicherungen suchen das heißt russland
kann dieses embargo zwar umgehen aber es
ist dann lange nicht mehr so profitabel
wie zuvor und dadurch wird natürlich
auch die russische wirtschaft
unzweifelhaft geschädigt aber es dauert
und das umland barcoo wird ja auch erst
angenommen dass es ende dieses jahres
tatsächlich dann entsprechend umgesetzt
werden vielen dank für das gespräch
frank umbach dankeschön das schon